well if you are looking to better your
overall health and wellness through a
holistic approach Wellness by Kelly the
sponsors of today's segment can
definitely help with that joining us
today is founder Kelly nimiro Kelly it's
always so great to see you thank you so
much good to see you let's get right to
it what I love most about everything
that you do is you can customize your
programs and you really work one-on-one
with all of your clients tell us a
little bit about that process and maybe
kind of from start to finish when you
bring someone on what's the first thing
you do yeah so that process is really
detail-oriented when I first talked to
someone we'll set up a 20-minute
Discovery call I'll learn about what
they're going through what their
symptoms are and then we'll put in a
request to run their lab so I look at
everything because I feel like for so
many years doctors looked over me where
I wasn't diagnosed with a thyroid
problem for like five years and it was
just passed over and passed over so
we'll look at all of their Labs from
their gut health to their stress
hormones to their female hormones and
understand why they're feeling the way
they're feeling and then we'll do a
90-minute session and where I recap
everything and then from there they
decide okay do I want to book six months
to really work on all this from a
lifestyle perspective so I can have the
sustainable result rather than taking
just some pill and covering them up and
masking the symptoms yeah so let's kind
of uncover what it means to take a
holistic approach yeah we talk about
that a lot but kind of break that down
for us I think that like I said so many
of us are told oh you're going to be on
this prescription for the rest of your
life I was told oh you have anxiety
you're going to take this anxiety
medication and that's what's going to
solve it but the reality is I was never
really given the tools to actually deal
with the anxiety so a holistic approach
really means looking at it from a
perspective of diet lifestyle and
supplements and managing whatever
symptoms it is from that perspective so
you don't have to be on a prescription
pill with all the side effects you can
really have a more long-term approach to
some of the things that you've been
dealing with for such a long time and it
feels so much better you have so much
more energy you don't have the digestive
side effects of being on all these
different pills it's like it's amazing
how much your health improves when you
can see things from a holistic approach
the other thing holistic means is that
you're looking at how your emotions how
how you feel in your day-to-day whether
that's stress overwhelm sadness those
different things are impacting how you
feel in your physical body and you know
even using things like your career as a
tool to help you feel better well Kelly
you get to experience working one-on-one
with people and seeing their progress
over time which I'm sure is just such a
rewarding experience on both sides of it
and I always say if you're not following
Kelly on social media look her up she
has helpful tips every day thank you so
much for being here and keeping us all
healthy and happy and you can visit
wellnessby kelly.com for more and check
out the special offer a premium
membership for just 29.99 per month
that's an amazing deal thank you Kelly
thank you we'll be right back